the queen and other world leaders are
paying tribute to archbishop desmond
tutu the anti-apartheid leader who
inspired millions to challenge a racist
government died sunday he was 90 years
old in a statement the queen said tutu
tirelessly championed human rights in
south africa and across the world former
president barack obama hailed him as a
moral compass and president biden and
the first lady spoke of the archbishop's
courage and warmth deborah potter looks
back at tutu's extraordinary life
the tiny clergy man with a twinkle in
his eye
a massive laugh and a dance in his step
born in the township of clarksdale south
africa desmond tutu went on to become a
nobel peace prize winner
a global campaigner for human rights and
a man who always spoke truth to power
whether it was a white racist regime or
corrupt african dictatorship
as south africa's first black archbishop
he unhesitatingly used his office to
bravely challenge the brutal racism of
the country's apartheid rulers the
primary violence and white people don't
want to hear this the primary terrorism
in this country comes from the
government
but equally he could turn that righteous
fury onto his own supporters in 1985
tutu fearlessly broke up an angry south
african mob and prevented them from
burning a man to death on suspicion of
being an apartheid spy
when the dark days of racial hatred
finally ended and tutu's longtime friend
and former south african president
nelson mandela was released from 27
years behind bars the irrepressible arch
as he is affectionately known could not
hold back his joy hey
freedom is coming freedom is coming and
it was mandela who appointed his friend
tutu to lead south africa's troost and
reconciliation commission
a body tasked with uncovering the truth
about the apartheid government's
brutality at times it moved tutu to
tears
the business of dismantling apartheid
was not all doom and gloom tutu had a
self-deprecating sense of humor one one
lady said to me hey bishop
if they do this when
you come here can you imagine what is
going to happen when nelson comes
quick to crack a joke or break out into
song and dance
the world is a little darker without him
he leaves behind a foundation committed
to human rights
but his real legacy is the wonderful
tale of how a diminutive pastor with a
big laugh
became a global conscience for the world
for cbs morning's debra patter
johannesburg
you know he really seemed to use his
oppression to empathize with others he
was a huge advocate in the lgbtq
community as well but my favorite book
the book of joy is a book about desmond
tutu and the dalai lama and one thing he
says in there is he says we should ask
how are we because we should
collectively all appreciate one another
and each other's achievements that's
right i know at one point in his life he
recognized that he had a powerful voice
and dean decided to use that voice as a
proponent for non-violence you know he
once said um overwhelmed by the extent
of evil he said it was necessary to open
the wound in order to cleanse it
incredible man between him and nelson
mandela they did so much for south
africa and that laugh
yeah
light up a room very memorable